good morning to everybody here all
counselors here and everybody that that
is watching uh welcome to this meeting
of the cabinet um getting straight into
business we've got the first item on the
agenda is apologies for absence uh we do
have some apologies for absence uh and
and um perhaps you would out yes we got
apologies from councelor coucher and
rock uh I know that um one is for
illness and counter counselor is
representing us at the West Midlands
combined Authority today in my
place and moving on then to disclosures
of interest um we do we have anybody
that wants to put a disclosure of
Interest onto any item that is on the
agenda
today anything that uh I think there is
some item terms the the the uh in the
budget maybe anybody's got any any
comment anything that they want to
declare on that one
no I don't think I need to declare it
because I'm allowed to speak about the
budget to come what may but I mean again
if the hvv comes into budget discussions
then I will L on fact that my husband is
a is a
um managing director of a fuel
Distribution Company as in the last time
I've taken ample advice on this but I am
allowed to speak freely on anything
relating to the budgets thank
you thank you leader um so the first
item yes the treasury management
strategy statement and annual investment
strategy to provide members with a
treasury management statement and annual
investment strategy for
2425 um there are two lengthy and
comprehensive appendices which I'm sure
everyone has read with a great deal of
interest and and detail um the main
thing to note on page 13 recommendation
one to approve the overall borrowing
limits 25 million and the short-term
borrowing limit of 16 million this is
primarily um if you turn to page
31 um those reflect the expected
borrowing or the possible borrowing
required for the murf and refuge
vehicles and possible Leisure Center
refurbishments um the other thing you
you may have noticed is that all of the
tables on page 26 27 and so forth
they're all estimates even going back
back to 22 23 technically they are
estimates because we haven't yet had the
final audit for those years but just
talking to Richard Richard assures me
that the audits but for
2223 and 23 21 sorry 2122 22 23 should
should be completed by September but
that's why if you look at those it does
say estimated rather than final um so
any questions on
that I have no questions um I think it's
been a a very thorough paper uh lays out
um completely the um the the the
position of the council uh and the
position of the funding that is coming
from um require from government Etc uh
so they there are recommendations on
page 13 and this of course will now go
forward to um Council for approval final
approval uh so the recommendations are
one to five on page 13 um are you going
to propose those yes I would like to
propose those recommendations one to5 to
cabinet for approval and are we have we
got and councelor call is prepared to
second that so are we all in favor good
thank you very much indeed thank
you moving on to the next item
uh it's the revenue and capital budget
uh and this is one again uh that is um
councelor Curtis will lead on although
I'm also named on that one as well so
that's on pages 69 to
132 thank you again leader um just a
note that that um that looking at note
four on on sorry recommendation four on
page 69 um a note has just been
circulated that has been there's a
revised mtfs and I'll just
read a statement that Richard has very
kindly provided me with uh this is a med
a revised medium-term Financial strategy
following the government's confirmation
of the local government Finance Finance
settlement for 2425 last week it is
unprecedented that they have moved so
far from the provisional settlement to
the final usually there is a smaller
amount of rounding but this year we have
seen oneoff additional resources in the
order of £1
172,000 for the council the changes
relate to the rural Services delivery
Grant an additional
55,000 Services Grant an additional 1ou
55 sorry 1,000 55,000 the services Grant
an additional 1,000 and a change to the
3% funding guarantee to a 4% gu funding
guarantee and an uplift to the core
spending power to give an additional
116,000 with this additional funding has
come a requirement for councils to
produce a productivity plan this
includes the transformation of services
to make better use of resources to take
advantage of advantages advances in
technology and better use of data to
inform decision- making and service
design and to reduce wasteful spending
within systems I'll come back to that in
a second in in recognition of this
requirement this additional funding has
been topped up to 200,000 and added to
the council plan and change program fund
this will deliver the efficiencies and
the productivity plan required with this
additional funding and Associated
allocation to the council plan and
change program the council's general
Reserve after 5 years now stands at 3.1
million just over the minimum general
fund balance of 3 million as required by
the section1
officer um
as yet we don't know from the central
government what their productivity plan
is um but it seems to me at least that
with the change program that we have
already we're already planning for this
Council we are actually ahead of the
game on that so I think that's a very
good step to take so that's that's the
update on the mtfs uh revised circulate
a revised mtfs has also been circulated
to everyone so the recommendations to
the Council R1 125 with the amended four
on page 69
um again I'm happy to take any questions
but there'll be a general discussion I
imagine on the budget sorry can I can I
just clarify on that particular item
items one and recommendations one and
two are resolved today at this committee
items two three four and five are
recommendations to council thank you
David thank you for that
clarification uh could I just ask uh one
question maybe the the officer can
clarify um we we we were told that um
the spending review means that the
council's only received the one-year
settlement this I think is the sixth
one-year settlement in a row I know that
there has been considerable uh
representations made by the local
government Association on this um as
because of the uncertainty that has
arisen around Local Government funding
uh to to to um go for longer term
settlements are there any indications
given that this um announcement uh
particularly with the productivity
Etc being included that there will be
any longer term settlements quite so
close to um Christmas as it did this
year uh is is is have we got any
indication from
government chairman thank
you so so this is the seventh one-year
settlement that we've had in in a row um
I think it's unlikely we're going to get
any further confirmation that we're
going to get a multi-year settlement
ahead of a general election
which let's face it we're planning for
for the Autumn this year that will be
therefore ahead of the the following
Year's um Financial settlement so from
that
perspective these are one-off resources
could could I also just draw members
attention to the the handouts which have
been distributed this this morning we
have
got this rather exciting form which is
headed the nndr 1 that's one of the
additional appendices that need to be
considered and approved by the cabinet
this is our estimate of how much
business rates will be collected by the
council in the coming year that under
reinforces the position in relation to
the business rate retention line on on
on on the um on the papers you've also
had circulated the results of the
business uh sorry the budget
consultation exerc exercise that's on
this P little pamphlet which is got item
five on the front of it so it gives the
results of the exercise which were
undertaken and we have had 172 responses
in that also included within that
particular pack is the report that was
made to the overview and scrutiny
committee on Friday which included all
of the alternate budget proposals coming
forward from um other groups the green
party and and the conservatives and and
the the result of the recommendation I'm
I'm sure the the chair of the O osc
would like to to talk to that report as
well as part of the
debates um would that um take place now
would over and scrutiny committee chair
would like to make any comment at that
at this point
from all right thank you thank you Mr
bman thank you junid yeah we we did look
at U the situation there was particular
comment around about about the
oneye um settlements which are not
conducive for future long-term planning
um again it does make sense um but like
you I don't think I think I'll be
holding my breath for the next few years
and if we were going to get a more than
a onee settlement you know I can't you
know imagine it'll be in the next two or
three years but I might be surprised but
but I won't hold my breath um certainly
we we looked at some of the the reports
we spoke um Mr Bor was there and uh
councelor Curtis were at the meeting as
well um we do consider that um you it
was talked about we've got a task and
finish group on on the budgets uh and
that was chaired by councelor Johnston
um and they had some some points that
that were raised that were fair and
reasonable but um certainly
I think the whole process um with money
coming at last minute makes it difficult
with uh uh you know for everybody to
plan properly I've got one small comment
today um obviously the extra paper
that's come around obviously things are
not lost the national non-domestic
rights return um paper can it come with
a magnifying glass please because I was
I'm trouble quite reading some of this
um you know when my eyes have started
getting a bit older now I'm not 21
anymore it
was quite difficult to to read but I can
understand that's only a small point
there so thank
you small
Point um councilor W hogin I believe you
also also wanted to
speak yeah I'm just seeking um also to
say that I'm disappointed that we've
only just got the budget consultation
results today and that of course and the
only 172 responses were were um were
received for that um I'd also like some
clarity please on um the update that we
were given about wasteful spending
within systems there was mention of that
that there was some going to be some
scrutiny over that do we have any more
details of that and uh also although
we've brought them to over the Inu
committee and to the budget budget
meetings uh will there be any regard to
the alternative budget proposals uh that
uh both lib Dems and the green party
have so both conservatives and the
greens have brought up brought to the
table thank
you uh I believe the OV and scrutiny
look did look at both Al alternative uh
budgets uh we did ask some questions
specific questions about um some of the
items that were in uh in the in the
alternative budgets I believe we in
particular there was one question that
was raised about the provision that was
needed for domestic abuse uh and I
believe we've now got figures and
updated figures uh for that uh Council C
are you able to kind of outline what
that that um what the updated
information that we have had um yes we
haven't got figures as such but I know
you certainly did
you well we we do have the figures but I
think the
overall um feel and I think might be
more sensible to circulate this perhaps
for your convenience rather than me
reading them out and not making um full
use of them the funding
over the past three years the housing
advisor the domestic abuse specialist
role has been funded through the
Domestic Abuse Act new burdens funding
Grant from central government because
that just rolls off the tongue um and
we're up to now 242 we've got a grant of
£37,000 now when we spoke about it it is
going to be kept under review but in
terms of the homelessness caused by
domestic violence I don't think at the
moment and this is continually under
review for this year we've not felt the
need to put in a um a bid application um
to support uh any sort of shortfall in
spending um and I certainly know uh
conversation with my um colleagues that
homelessness is the end of a very very
long um process uh and that is certainly
being addressed by a multi- agencies as
it goes along um so at at the moment you
know whilst we absolutely get your
concern um for such a difficult
situation um at the moment we don't feel
at this point in time that we we need to
adjust the budget to address a shortfall
in that
area chief
executive it's not in relation to the
domestic abuse issue at all it was just
a respond to the points in relation to
the budget consultation so on Friday the
budget consultation results were
published and they were circulated by
email to counselors of course
cabinet are making recommendations today
to Council on the 26th of February
that's when the final decisions will be
made in relation to the budget so the
results of the budget consultation will
be available for the two weeks ahead of
that that that particular exercise in
relation to the exercise that the budget
review group and the overview and
scrutiny committee have undertaken
they've looked at the proposals they've
assessed whether they are clear
achievable and financially sound that
was what happened at the osc last week
it was then and to be fair we haven't
received any instructions to include any
of the budget proposals that came
through that process within the amended
schedule that's now being recommended to
council so from that perspective the
cabinet unless we're hearing any
otherwise are not including any of those
revised budget proposals at this
stage of course is still open for um
opposition groups to raise amendments at
Council on the 26th of February in line
with the proposed which have already
been discussed and gone through the
budget process if they're not
incorporated into the draft budget
today thank you thank you for clarifying
that uh so we've got before us the um
unless anybody's got any additional
comments that they want to make and give
bearing in mind that the um the
consultation uh will be circulated
around there was also um appendix 3 was
the business consultation we must forget
that as well uh I chaired that uh I've
got C Curtis wants to come in councel W
hoggins that wants to come in thank you
leer and just picking up a obviously the
I accept that the public consultation
has only just been um
completed but I think looking down page
three um where we asked about asked for
consultation on a number of
proposals I think we can be fairly
satisfied you know no budget is going to
please all people all of the time I
think we we have to accept that that's
realistic and I think we are also here
um the public consultation it's not a
referendum it is a consultation but um
just looking some of the headline
figures down here the first item down
here £85,000 to maintain support for UBS
75% uh either strongly agree or agree
with that
68% um support the crime advisors
63% um in favor of £250,000 continued
residence from the ongoing cost of
living crisis 54% and I'm really pleased
with this you know 54% of approve of the
additional 500,000 going towards the
climate change carbon reduction
targets and you know one of the more
controversial elements down here the
hvo um 60 6 7% either in favor or
neither in favor nor against only 33%
actually against that additional
investment in reducing emissions across
the district so I think overall I mean
there are some fairly looking at some of
the comments they are some interesting
comments individually but looking at the
percentage of approval against uh not
approval I think we can not be
complacent by any means but I think we
can be reassured that what we are
proposing in this budget broadly
speaking chimes with residents
expectations thank you thank you
data councelor Trump I believe you want
to comment and then we'll yeah I just I
just thought I'll come back on this um
it's quite nice of all councelor curses
was using the St strongly agreeing and
agree first two columns for for the ones
where we got 75% 30 68% yeah no problem
and then suddenly we come down to the
250,000 for the hvo we then added all
the first three columns so we went from
being a 40 46% to strong strongly agree
and agree
to uh 60 67% because we're not including
the neither agree or or disagree so I
think if to be consistent it would have
been fair to say the 75% for the uh
85,000 for the UB and when we come down
to the
250,000 it was 46% are strongly agree or
agree so just to be just to be
consistent thank you thank you but
everybody will have these when it comes
to the debate at the council and that is
where a lot of the debate will be held
and and it will be a debate that will be
based on um proper information that has
been circulated around to people before
then uh and uh just note the as I
mentioned before the business
consultation uh meeting that was held
here it was an extremely good uh meeting
um more than turned people turned up
than in previous years I believe um so
and and I was very happy to chair that
meeting uh with the business members of
the community so with the um the slight
change to the append um the could you
just read how they change to the rec in
relation to the recommendation for
there's been a revised proposal a
revised um medium-term financial plan
circulated this morning and therefore
recommendation for that the proposed
medium-term Revenue budget detailed at
appendix six as amended be approved and
recommended to council okay do I H have
um those people that U anybody want
would like to propose that yes thank you
leader I'll I'll propose the
recommendations to Cabinet one and two
and then the recommendations to council
three four and five as amended four okay
councel Co are you happy to second that
thank you very much indeed those in
favor
please okay thank you very much indeed
we're moving on to the next item um
which is um the notice a motion on the
Church Street uh car park uh and that is
on page
133 and um this was a notice of motion
presented to the Council on the of
December uh with a
recommendation uh and I'm going to say
change the recommendation slightly uh it
would the recommendation will read we
recommend that the designation of the
seven spaces marked out for council's
leader and chair of the council are
removed and also the customer reserving
spaces for councilors at times of public
meetings however we question the the use
of public money money to address this
and recommend that no public money is
used to the uh to to address um this um
it should that just to explain um the
yellow lines are beginning to wear away
we will let those wear away um I would
like to see more disabled spaces however
in the car park and I'd like to see that
addressed and this is a personal comment
from me I I do not like the idea of cson
tax payers money being used for for
counselor's convenience uh I am there
prepare therefore prepared to be able to
fund uh put something into the pot to
fund any changes um that will needed to
be made but I I I do not see that there
should be any designated spaces for
councelors either at uh for during the
the week or at Council meetings either
thank you so that is the um and since it
came from the council Mo the notice
motion came from um Council W huggings
do you want to address that and are you
also prepared to
contribute what do you mean to
contribute
sorry towards a,s that it will cost to
to to to remove the the space was ,000
spoke to Tony perks about it on Friday
the, is is a nominal figure that's been
put in there and as as as Tony said
there there may be talk to go into there
all you need to do is to notify all
counselors and staff that there are no
designated car parking points now and
everybody May Park as they wish within
that car park so no there is no budget
needed for this you just gently let the
markings disappear from the car park um
find it somewhat ging uh that uh your uh
suggesting ,000 pounds is a waste of
council money when in fact you're
proposing all of this green money being
spent 250,000 H vo but you know we'll
wait till full Council before we debate
that thoroughly and properly thank you
uh
councel yeah it was funny enough it
wasn't on the agenda to OC on Friday but
I think councelor Ral brought it up and
we did have a little bit debate about
this and and Mr Mr Perks gave the
impression
that any costs were negligible uh and it
could be done easily um at an
appropriate time when that the people
were doing line markings anyway so I I
don't think the cost is is particularly
relevant here um is the fact that the
whole relevance is that there won't be
any uh demarcation between councel
spaces and members of the public so and
and and officers as well so I I think
the point about the cost is is tenuous
um and I think it just needs to be done
sooner than than later and I know with
my other hat on the street Linings uh
are not best they don't like the cold
the the wet the frost bit like us really
um so therefore they likely to aad quite
quickly and that gives us the
opportunity to to to make corrective
action but I don't think it's
particularly honorous to the council no
councel grow
cut
thank you leader um you know obviously I
support um this move to uh extend the
essentially egalitarian culture of this
organization and um I just wondering why
that um this has come up as a priority
now when the previous administration had
been in for 22 years um but I'd also
like to recommend uh that the leader and
the um chairs parking spaces are moved
out to being disabled just to um support
um more um minorities thank you I I
certainly recommend that we we should
look at more having more disabled SP
parking spaces in there um I I I've
never used the um the designated space I
don't see that there should be a
designated spaces but it's it's just
that I don't like the idea of public
money being used to um to make it to
make the changes um Council the chief
executive would like to come in thank
you chairman so
could I just check the the revised
wording then in relation to the
recommendation that you're making to
council um and and and and just
following up on on some of the debate is
it therefore if I if I just read what I
I think it is that the we we recommend
yeah soorry we recommend that the
designation of the seven spaces marked
out for Council as
leader are we saying therefore whilst
they're they're not physically removed
they're ignored at this stage
and the custom of reserving spaces for
counselors is removed because this is
where we put the lollipops out we won't
put the lollipops out at this time and
and and therefore we will not be
incurring any expenditure on this item
yeah um but but but that in any any
future um any future sort of review we
we look at the disabled spaces um
because I believe that there are
insufficient number of disabled spaces
in the car park current okay sorry that
that matter wasn't covered by the direct
motion but but we can capture that in
the in the preamble to the to the minute
chairman thank you are you happy that
with that um I I will propose that any
changes anybody else want to Second it
Council grut uh are we happy with that
okay thank you moving
on we now have the uh statement of
community involvement and this would
normally be um counc culture but uh he
is at the West Midland's combined
Authority as we speak um so I I'm happy
to take that on as as lead for that are
there anybody any questions um that are
needed on that item uh and uh we have an
officer here if if required to answer
any questions um on on the uh statement
of community involvement uh and just to
be clear I believe that this is to do
with the planning um um the role of the
the planning role of the council that
this community statement of community
involvement is um is has been brought
together yes thank you chair uh yes so
this is a revised um um statement of
community vment that went out to
consultation at the end of last year um
but essentially yes it sets out how the
planning service will consult on
planning policy documents and planning
applications essentially and kind of
planning related matters um and also
gives guidance about um local
communities um how they engage on their
planning matters for example local
communities that prepare neighborhood
development plans it sets out um the the
regulations legislations and guidance
for how that consultation be should be
undertaken as well thank you very much
and on page5 145 uh for those people
that would like to to know more there
are some changes and the main changes
are listed uh and they are listed at the
top of page 145 and it's to to improve
the consultation U with um the the
people in in the area on um both whole
but they're not they're not major um
changes I understand uh but could you
clarify just that there are some
changes yes thank you chair so yes the
the main reason for the consultation was
to remove a lot of the covid
restrictions because we have to do an
emergency update in 2020 when covid hit
to enable us to continue doing
consultation and virtually using
technology rather than face to face
because obviously that wasn't possible
at the time so um following obviously
the end of covid U restrictions we've
updated the purpose of the conentration
was to update so minor changes to take
out um reference to those restrictions
and also to make sure it's kept up to
date with Chang in legislation and
guidance Etc so yeah we I think we had
24 uh responses to the consultation um
and a number of um um as you say chair
relatively minor updates are recommended
um to Council in the revised version for
adoption um just to just to kind of
clarify
um on matters to make it even more clear
as to um how the consultation is
undertaken thank you and just say
5.1.3 sets out that it is a duty of
every Council to prepare and adopt an
seci uh and uh
7.1 uh outlines the in conclusion the
reasons for the recommendation and the
purpose of the seci uh which is how the
council intends to engage with
communities through the planning process
in order to comply with the law on it so
that is the um the recommendations are
on page 143 recommendations one uh that
the revised statement uh be uh adopted
I'll bring you in just a moment I'm just
reading out the recommendations uh and
that the delegated authority be given to
to the head of development in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for planning and economic development to
make minor Ed editorial changes to the
sci should they be required councelor
Crump you want to come in yeah we we
discussed this quite a bit at um over
you and scrutiny and like most canes we
sometimes go off on a tangent you
sometimes a near tangent sometimes a not
so close tangent
um and yeah it's quite noticeable um I
appreciate the fact that the changes to
theci were min
um it was noticeable we'd only had 24
responses and it was also noticeable was
commented that we got 41 District
councilors so not even every District
councelor commented and obviously when
you saw the P people there were there
others and I think it it created a
debate about a couple of things um one
about uh the planning
process um and how it impinged some
impacted on some of the smaller councils
that met infrequently some meet meet
every week some you know some meet more
than that um so some discussion about
the 21-day consultation period Etc and
obviously a statutory requirement and
there's potentially ways that the re
relevant documents could be reviewed in
advance lot or or some preparation just
to make sure they're able to respond and
I think it was accepted by Mr Kord that
um there were things that could be done
differently potentially consultations
could be easier to access
online um but I think in in summary that
um there were potential solutions to
this that members and officers could
work together to assist parish councils
and um residents to engage better um
obviously we had 172 responses to the
budget uh and over in scrutiny committee
um we'll be having a work plan work plan
an item on about council's public
engagement Outreach and communication
particularly in the more rural uh
settlements as well so um it it was it
was a fair debate um no particular
issues with with the um the the initial
report um but yeah I think we we have
got to engage better um and see if we
can get more responses and I think
that's beenn knowledge and it was cross
Party Support on the fact we wanted to
to have a work item that so yeah just
somewh that I say thank you yeah I I was
um at the at the back of the OV and
scrutiny committee when that was raised
and uh and some points some good points
were made about the need for flexibility
particularly for Parish councils that
don't meet very very often and maybe by
monthly uh I think those points were
were taken on board and and uh you know
understood that we do need to make sure
that we are Consulting adequately and
and properly uh and u i I say those
those were things that were taken on
board by the officers cons I'm pretty
sure at that time but to say there was a
good debate at the O and scrutiny on
this item Okay so we've got the before
us the recommendations that will now go
to
council and um
uh have we got somebody that wants to
propose on that one otherwise I'm happy
to propose anybody that second councelor
Groot that was second and are we in
favor everybody in favor thank you very
much indeed moving on to the next item
which is the uh review of the housing
strategy action plan inequality impact
assessment and this is councelor
Kohl's thank you leader
um what we we have before us today
recommendations that the uh sustainable
homes sustainable communities statford
on a district housing strategy 2126 be
noted that the action plan detailed
within the report be agreed and that we
also note the equality impact assessment
which is um new for this report
um from my point of view from my this is
an important document it uh shows the
work between uh both the housing and the
strategy portfolios um and it has some
extremely good work in it and some some
uh good actions to uh maintain and
develop as we go along which are in
support of what uh we wish to achieve
within the district um I know Council
CER is was also extremely pleased with
this and happy to move it forward
um there are some obviously some targets
um that have been had to be adjusted or
need to be have the um Target dates
moved in order to accommodate changes in
circumstances and what have you those
will be monitored as we go along and um
I know certainly the officers are Keen
to to deliver what is within this report
so um from my point of view I'm happy to
recommend that these these three items
be noted and moved um I wonder if I
could possibly ask ask a question um the
um on on page 188 with action five um it
does does say about uh things like
Independent Living specialized housing
with support or care in accordance with
identified needs that this is a count
there is a a relationship here with the
County Council um the comments are made
about insufficient resources at County
Council and District Council to assess
the need and then there's also something
about the new supported housing
regulatory oversight act
2023 uh on which government guidance is
expected shortly uh I just wondered
whether you could um um or maybe the
officer could do do it on on your behalf
uh about the relationship with the
County Council and what what the
insufficient resources there are and
also what guidance is expected shortly
and um that Renata is here to give her
expse infinitely a better idea to ask
just to for my clarification uh when are
we expecting the government guidance and
and what is the issue with the County
Council just so that I understand the
the the resources
issues
hello um County are preparing for an
inspection and they've also had quite a
move around of Staff who deal with um
specialized housing they've also been
quite hit quite badly with sick leav so
that's been the delay there it's not
been entirely County Council because at
the district council my team I've had
somebody on longterm sickly for almost
two years so delay there and then we
have got the new supported housing
regulatory oversight act which cuts
across all of this it places legal Duty
on the local
Authority we haven't got the guidance
yet but we're expecting it and this is
particularly about members will have
seen in the Press about things like
exempt
accommodation if you're wondering what
I'm talking about this is the ones for
people with special needs some of the
private providers I'm sure you've seen
in the Press about the bad condition of
the properties um and charging a load of
money so I said all that is actually
related um and we will be doing this
this year partly because we need to
specialized housing just to say is about
developments that's purpose buil
accommodation for people at the higher
level of needs so like mental health or
learning disabilities that's not to say
some of those people can't manage in
general needs with adequate support but
all that is really going to be cutting
host the supported Housing Act which the
government's bought
in I'm just wondering whether this is
because there is um we a need for update
once the government guidance comes uh
and once we have an update on exactly
where everybody else is this is
something that I you know I'm just very
keen that we should um we should be on
top of so if if at the stage when we've
got that information you could keep us
um keep it reviewed that would be
appreciated course and I mean I can even
if it doesn't come should be coming
fairly shortly but that's what they say
but I mean even if it does come I'll
make sure I'll include a note when I do
the July um or the next six months if it
comes before I can do you a briefing not
let you know yeah because we're talking
here about um a whole range of of a
specialized need for people with
dementia and disabilities uh and um
physically physical dis disabilities as
well as um mental ill health uh so it's
something that you know important it is
important an important area thank you
very much councelor W
hoggins yes thank you um I'm just uh
very concerned that there's not enough
financial provision being made within
your proposed budget to deal with the
implications of this action plan um and
within the action plan that we've got
before us today there are no financial
implications that have been costed there
for us to see and by the very regard of
it we don't actually yet know um what
we're facing and uh whether whether you
know as I said I'm just very concerned
that the libd budget does not have uh
enough um provision made within it for
the implications of this of this AC
action plan and what it could mean for
for the district and most importantly
for our residents and our most
vulnerable residents thank you I I
believe that um there is something in
the budget there there's also something
currently in in the um in the council
but there in the change plan uh we have
actually indicated quite clearly that um
those kind of changes are are the things
that need to be planned for in the next
two years um Can perhaps I don't know
whether um rat or um
Annette will you've got uh the any any
further comments to make on
that thank you lady yeah just to comment
really that we have put a sum of money
in the budget for next year we're very
aware of the consultation exercise
that's currently underway so we don't
know the outcome of that yet um and
there will be a piece of work that we
envisage will need to be rolled out to
all local authorities so we're thinking
probably in the first instance some
consultancy um with a view to us then
taking that forward ourselves
thank you that so it's it's already in
the budget and it's also in in some of
the Amendments that are are being put
forward as well so thank you very much
in indeed for that uh
and that was a question you know all my
questions were were asked but I'll
probably have a word with you at another
stage as well uh and so we've got two
recommendations three recommendations my
apologies there um councelor Co are you
prepared to um propose that because it's
coming under your um
portfolio sorry yes
um yes I would like to um move them
there'll be a sort of unseemly Scrabble
while I find my page again I your pardon
uh so it is the recommendations on yes
it is the recommendations on the on
page8 five yes thank you
yeah thank you yes uh yes the
recommendations that the uh strategy for
2126 be noted uh that the revised action
plan be agreed and that the equality
impact assessment be noted so that's uh
note the report agree the action plan
and note the equality impact assessment
um I'd like to propose that and I will
second that one thank you very much
indeed all those agreed agreed happy to
AC accept that report thank you very
much
indeed and moving on we now have the
um the business improvement district
ballot pages one 217 uh to
242 and
um the chief executive will make an
introduction
here thank you chairman um two points
the first point is the title and and and
and discussion within the summary we're
talking about a bid ballot here for the
business improvement district not ofo
that the bid boundary has changed that's
very clear within the uh prospectus that
has been
circulated also want to make the point
that there's been conversations and and
correspondence received by the council
in relation to the current bid ballot to
be absolutely clear the bid ballot will
conclude on the 22nd of February and we
urge all business es and any with a vote
to actually cast their vote either for
or against the proposals which are in
the bid ballot perspectus and today we
should concentrate ourselves on just
whether the council supports or not it's
it's it's a neutral recommendation at
the moment as to whether to support or
not the 10 votes that we have in
relation to um the bit Bell proposals
thank you uh yes Jo just to underline
that we have 10 um votes on on the bid
and this is to to decide how we will use
our 10 votes this is not anything to do
with how the bid will conduct itself or
or anything else the under the
legislation um the the bid is uh any
projects or Services provided by the bid
are in addition to Services provided by
local authorities improvements may
include but are not limited to extra
safety security cleansing and
environmental measures but they are in
addition to what would be provided by
the local Authority but that is for the
bid themselves to um decide on their
program of uh work uh and the way they
will um the way that their work will be
conducted our decision today is about
how we would use the 10 votes um in that
bid ballot and um so we're being asked
whether we would vote in favor of um
using our bids for in favor of
continuing with the bid uh against the
bid or abstaining on the bid and then
authorizing the deputy chief executive
to vote in the business uh improvement
district ballot on behalf of the council
for those 10 votes and then the
arrangements for regular liais on
meetings between the portfolio holder uh
the head of development and
representatives of the bid to be
formalized with the assistant of Legal
Services where required so our decision
today is how we will use our 10 votes uh
anybody that wants to make any comment
at on at this
stage no comments to be
made councilor calls um I
think although this is a neutral
recommendation I think my my feeling is
that you know on due consideration that
we would be sensible to vote for and to
support the
continuing um vid uh it does add it has
had its difficulties but it it is an
addition to what is provided in the town
and is a a matter for and by uh
businesses involved rather than the a
local Authority working with them I
think is definitely positive for
businesses and residents of the
district and indeed we are an
internationally recognized town and lots
of visitors come to the town um and we
certainly need um the the the the extra
services that a bid can produce so uh I
say this is just about the way we will
use our 10 votes uh and um my proposal
is that we will use those 10 votes to
vote for the um the continuation of the
business improvement district uh do I
have a seconded to that councelor Gest a
seconded that uh anybody wants to make
any other comments then could we put
that to the vote are are you in favor of
that all all in favor thank you very
much
indeed moving on with Ward we've got
issues arising from the overview and
scrutiny committee councelor Crump do
you have anything extra to add to the
comments that you've made previously um
yeah just a couple Council joury please
um there was obviously um we have the
far and rescueing and I was the other
side of the
table um there's discussion about that
and lots of I think K was there taking
some information down and it was good to
see that members were able to get first
firstand accurate information rather
than potentially am to rely on
information that was been uniquely
interpreted shall we say so it was good
to get you know the details
Etc uh we had
orbiting um where there was lots of
discussions a very brief presentation
presentations now from guest speakers a
very short note rather than have a
minute sorry have an hour debate um item
on the agenda and 55 minutes is that is
done with a presentation and five
minutes on on questions it's the other
way around there so I think that's a lot
but it's working a lot better um I will
circulate these these minutes um but
we've got some there was obviously
raised concerns regarding the frequent
recur items repairs whil you while
emergency pirs were mostly good followup
procedures were often in adequate un
left residents in different situations
um there needed to be more like we
thought that orbit needed to hold the
contractors more to
account um because they seem to you know
some of the contractors were saying the
job was done and they weren't
potentially being done to the
appropriate standard and therefore it
then caused other problems so we were
mindful that they got it right first
time
um there was also um um we found that
21% of homes that were still not at EPC
b c and obviously the potential issues
dump and
mold the contact email the MP and C the
email
address um wasn't being operated as well
as it used to be and there was delays in
getting information
back uh a call a serious item around
antisocial
Behavior Uh we felt that some of the
contact center people needed more
training particularly around
gdpr um and they some members felt um
these operators were hiding Beyond gdpr
and actually understanding why um one
example was um a resident was founding
on behalf as his mother-in-law and had
got permission and an already sent the
details that that person was able to um
speak on that person's behalf and they
they wouldn't accept it and the thing
was they were only phing up to do Orit
to FIV to tell them that they weren't
going to be the person was going to be
in hospital so they weren't going to be
there uh for the appointment so don't
bother turning up oh no we can't take
this information and surprise surprise
they turned up and put on outed we
didn't catch you you weren't at home
well we already knew that and it just
shows
some I can't think of the right word the
word I was going to use isn't isn't the
best so um FL was in the system how
about that I think there was some we'll
use that phrase um there was all issues
about the community build post and local
housing offices that they felt that
still were were better than the previous
things and we also felt it still needed
to be more prioriti
prioritization of process and procedures
to help the yly and most
vulnerable um but yeah there there's
quite a few it was a good dep right um
it will be part of the task and finish
group some information that's coming out
um and Orit have given the offer to
engage with members regarding their work
program their repairs and upgrate
upgrade program as well um but yeah it's
I think it was worthwhile exercise even
to
get the senior director and deputy
director aware of some of the things
that weren't particularly happening well
so that was that one uh
bid uh again
um there were some concerns regarding
the representation of smaller businesses
and ensuring good value for money um but
in overall terms it was suggested that
continuation of the bid was better than
the alternative of not having one um
I've been contacted over the weekend by
uh a couple of residents who who got
some concerns which I've passed on uh
one of which I don't think was it was a
difficult one but one I've passed on to
the chief executive um but I think
that's for post ballot rather than you
know to deal with the ballot and I think
it might be an opportunity to have the
bid uh process in the work program uh
later uh in the year or early next year
to um to see how how things are settled
down how things are differently what can
be done in Improvement and I I did hear
you saying you you're going to have
legal involvement in debates and then
all sorts of different people so I think
we need to look at the process because
if
these things have been raised and we
don't address them it's I it's good for
democracy I think you know that's my
whole point of in scrutiny um because
you can't unless you know there always
potentially be allegations about
different things and if you don't answer
them or don't look at them you put
yourself in a rable
position uh and the only other thing uh
we spoke about the task and finish
groups on the housing associations is
going very well uh that's going well and
the public houses task and finish group
we haven't got a site visit yet organize
but we're off we try no seriously um
again there's some officers are working
um really well uh with with members uh
in getting information as well so there
are are some interesting things coming
out of that
and as part of the the budget task and
finish group um there was a
recommendation that uh over in scrutiny
had a review of the financial
Arrangements concerning statford
Christmas Market 2023 to the work
program which allows for the work to be
completed in good time before the 20
2024 Market is in place um and I believe
that um this is come to Cabinet now in
March I'm whether that's right or not oh
good David nodding which is good news so
again we'll be looking at that um that
and then the other thing again uh later
in the year probably August um would be
the statement of community involve oh
Community involvement not necessarily
just assment of community involvement um
yeah
so it was a long meeting but most most
people stayed which was good so thank
you for that um thank you very much um
I've got a question to ask myself but
councelor GR do you want to come in
thank you councelor Crump um I just
wanted a clarification there because I
didn't make it to the end of the meeting
I didn't have that stamer on me so I um
missed the conversation about the
Victoria Market as far as I was aware
the um conversations we're going to be
having in cabinet were to do with the
arrangements and health and safety not
particularly the
financial um side of the Christmas
Market that um Victorian Market that was
my
understanding
I was I was advised by Mr Perks so
um we can be flexible this and we can
have a discussion between now could you
could get some clarification on that
because I I I don't think there I think
there's been a difference of of what
maybe when the minutes come out we'll be
able to check that uh but my question is
um on the orbit one there is to be a um
um there is to be a major change with
the the director um leaving um so I do
hope that that means that we uh when
when we are looking both in the council
but also over in scrutiny that we are
able to keep that lays ongoing and
basically I'm the reason I'm asking at
that is when will be will we be
reporting back on the task and finish
group I gave a quite a lengthy report
into that uh working group because I
think my area is either the first or the
second area of number for number of
orbit houses and the issues that I've
had with repairs but also t uh mold damp
and mold are considerable uh so I'd be
very very and at the moment I've never
been in um asked to come to um to talk
to the task and finish group at all uh
but uh I'm happy to do so if required
yeah so I think the report's back due
before Easter um so there's lots of work
questionnaire we did a real we sorry
that's the Royal we um the net did a lot
of the work but and her um s yeah and
and the chair Sarah so um there's a lots
of really good information it was a
really comprehensive question it's it's
probably the one of the best
questionnaires we've done for a long one
it's a good um could say it's a good
form of community involvement couldn't
we on that one um consultation but I
think so there's lots of stuff to go
through um we've had quite a few lots of
uh input from the members of the T can
finish grip but also from people from
other couns who whove put forward
processes and as well so um and what we
propos to do then is the the feedback
and then get once the paper's out to get
orbit back within 12 months after that
as well to see how things have changing
the other thing I forgot to mention it's
just come to me was the out of hour
service this is the one where um orbit
you know admited they weren't uh as as
strong as robust as they should have
been and they've got a new out of ours
or will be getting a new out of ours
provider for residents who've got you
know suddenly um something comes through
the roof uh you water leakage or
something like that and they feel that
that should help the situation as well
so I forgot to mention that can I bring
the chief executive at this stage in
chairman thank you it was just in
reference to the departure of Paul
Richards who presented to the commit uh
committee on on Friday he he's in post
until the end of March a pleasure just
before cabinet this morning with meeting
his successor so we're going to have a
gentleman called Trevor Graham seems to
be the only first name so Paul Richards
and now Trevor Graham and the chief
executive Phil Andrew anyway so um
Trevor Graham will absolutely continue
in the role that Paul has done for us in
in in the past that longer term there'll
be a split there in responsibilities
whereas Paul Richards covered both
customer services and repairs there'll
be two director positions moving into
the future one for customer services and
one for
repairs uh I think that probably is a a
wise decision but um I would be I would
actually um welcome an introduction to
to Trevor grahe at some point point
because Paul Richards has been very
helpful when I have had some very very
difficult issues uh with orbit so moving
on from that um thank you very much
indeed for the report on the ovan
scrutiny Part D is cabinet committees we
have nothing to report there part e is
on block items um oh councelor Curtis
you wanted to bring It come ink yes I
appreciate I should have raised um
anything I wanted to speak about on
items 10 or 11 on at the beginning of
the meeting May I just make a very brief
comment though on the climate change
panel
minutes is is at your discretion on this
point um it since since I shair that one
it is up my discretion so please thank
you very much I just councel guest as
well just noting the minutes um there's
an awful lot of status is
ongoing ongoing and ongoing and ongoing
and I I think I would like to see a
little less ongoing and some actually
targets met in there so just a a comment
that thank you very letting make letting
me make that
leader Ju Just yeah just on on on on
that one um there is actually U some
good news uh but we can't actually
announce at the moment but there will be
some good news um and um I I will take
that point on board councelor giz um I
just thought we'd all quite like to hear
from Council are passingham regarding
the fire service U when they came to osc
on Friday um is that the appropriate uh
part C issues arising from OC shouldn't
we hear from Council passingham about
the fire service because he had to sit
because Council Crump is not able
to can I just come back in on the bit
about the climate change panel because
Council ctis and I were on the same page
there um because I say exactly the same
point about the ongoing and we wanted
some time line about about that as well
so
yeah yes the point uh on the fire
service is we if anybody wants any
questions councelor Crump was not able
to chair that meeting H it was actually
um counc counc passingham that chaired
that meeting because of the the interest
that councelor the the part that
councelor Crump plays at wari County
Council I don't know whether there's
anything you wanted to raise at that uh
about the uh fire service coming to the
overiew and scrutiny in order to
complete the uh the report on the OV and
scrutiny
committee I have got a report here um
which um with a few points of concern
shall I go through those yeah right so
um obviously there was um the Chief Fire
Ben Brooks gave the report and uh
councelor Crump also is portfol the
County Council gave the report and they
did emphasize that there was they were
seeking to guarantee provision of fire
service response times which at the
moment can't be met because of the
the the situation with retained fire
Services um but there was quite a number
of concerns um that were expressed um
bidford in particular has um got a an
issue in that they've got quite good
response times for their retained uh
firefighters but would possibly suffer
in in with these changes which would be
um putting these on the bidford on a
surge status
um well there was some concern about
statford being left more vulnerable uh
the sound of the county big rural area
um with quite a journey time from
statford or or from um wellsborne would
be uh you know possibly very vulnerable
um there was concern about whether
they'd be in a significant in in
instance where there'd be enough
appliances
around uh and
um they
also um the the response times to those
remote villages we thought was a bit
optimistic and in those remote uh
villages the housing stock is possibly
quite old and a bit uh very vulnerable
to to fire so that was also a concern
and
but then people thought that with the
outcry about re removing these retained
fire services that maybe there should be
a recruitment drive for uh oncore
firefighters and that all that we wanted
con confirmation about cross across
County
cooperation um for instance Morton in
the marsh is a lot nearer to many of the
villages south of shipston in terms of a
response for fire but um obviously uh
the Chief Fire officer and uh councelor
Crump um were in a difficult position in
terms of of resources and they they they
um reassured us as much as they could
that they would get the resources and
they would guarantee as much of the the
response times as they could um but
there was still a certain amount of
nervousness from councilors representing
those areas but um yeah thanks can can I
say I appreciate the fact that you've
given your your report on on what came
forward with the ovm scrutiny committee
I believe we will be doing an official
response to the consultation and I think
that will come from councelor Gest uh
and um I wasn't able to put my views
forward obviously because I was sitting
at the back uh I'm not a member of the
OV scrutiny committee but certainly as a
representative uh of the town of oler um
where we of course had the Dreadful
tragedy that occurred um about 16 years
ago um we we have strong views about and
I I attended the oler town council's
consultation on on uh on on fire
services so I I think we will be um it
will be something that will be discussed
at Council uh but we will be putting in
an official uh response so thank you
very much indeed
sorry this no it won't be at this
Council next Council but it'll be when
the consultation period is finished
we'll be finalizing our response to the
fire
service okay moving on then we've got uh
on block items part e uh these are um
items in this section the reports and
recommendations will be approved on
block unless a request is made to the
leader at the start of the meeting for
the item discussed to be discussed and I
have had no uh request for any of those
items to be discussed so with it's the
cabinet work program the climate change
panel and uh uh that that's the items
that will be on block are you happy to
accept those on block thank you and then
partf other matters urgent business I've
had no notification of urgent business
um so I declare this meeting